Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
A primera vista, esta pintura
tal vez no parece algo especial,
pero es una de las pinturas
más estudiadas en la historia del arte.
Se titula "Las meninas",
o "La familia de Felipe IV",
y es una pintura de Diego
Velázquez de 1656,
que representa una escena en la
vida de la corte real española.
Una infanta bien vestida, rechaza
un vaso de agua de una criada,
mientras que un enano
se burla de un perro.
Una segunda enana está a su lado,
mientras el propio artista
posa en el lienzo.
Dos personas más susurran en el fondo,
y una tercera parece
salir de la habitación,
y ¿por qué no habría de hacerlo
si parece que no pasa nada?
Hasta el perro parece aburrido.
Pero presta más atención.
Las dos personas reflejadas
en el espejo borroso del fondo,
que uno pasa por alto a primera vista,
no son otros que el rey Felipe IV
y la reina Mariana,
y parecen cambiar la escena de una simple
representación de la vida cortesana
a un retrato real.
Y con esta información,
podemos entender
mucho más el cuadro
y por qué ha cautivado
al espectador durante siglos.
En primer lugar,
está el contexto histórico.
Cuando se pintó "Las meninas"
al final del reinado de Felipe,
el Imperio Español estaba en decadencia,
tras sufrir una derrota en
la Guerra de los Treinta Años,
así como dificultades
económicas y políticas.
El propio rey había sufrido
también un infortunio personal:
perdió a su primera esposa
y a su único heredero al trono
antes de volverse a casar.
Pero la pintura oculta su esfuerzo
por proveer alimentos a la familia.
Incluso oculta la edad
avanzada del monarca
mediante la difuminación del espejo.
Lo que sí vemos en el centro
geométrico de la tela,
brillantemente iluminada
por la luz de la ventana,
es a la infanta Margarita Teresa,
única hija legítima del rey
en ese momento.
Su aspecto brillante y saludable
es una imagen idealizada del futuro
de este imperio en apuros.
Sin embargo, la infanta no es
el único tema central de la pintura.
Mediante el uso hábil
de la perspectiva
y el tamaño natural de la obra,
--un lienzo de 3,18 m x 2,76 m--
Velázquez desdibuja la frontera
entre arte y realidad
y crea una tridimensionalidad
en la que podemos entrar.
La línea entre el techo y la pared
converge hacia la puerta abierta,
creando aún más la sensación
del cuadro como un espacio físico,
visto desde la perspectiva
del espectador.
De este modo, el foco de atención
son el público y el mundo real
subrayados por las tres figuras
que miran directamente al espectador.
Pero todavía hay otro punto focal.
La línea formada por la iluminación
lleva al centro de la pared posterior,
al espejo que refleja a la pareja real.
Y su posicionamiento
en relación con el espectador
ha llevado a toda clase
de interpretaciones
de la obra en su conjunto.
El espejo podría estar reflejando al rey
y la reina que posan para su retrato,
¿o acaso refleja el lienzo?
¿Y qué opinamos del hecho
de que Velázquez nunca pintara
el retrato real aquí aludido?
¿Podría la pintura, en cambio,
ilustrar su propia creación?
Con la incorporación
del espejo a la obra,
Velázquez elevó el arte de la pintura
de su percepción como un simple oficio
a un esfuerzo intelectual.
Con sus tres puntos centrales en pugna,
"Las meninas" captura el contraste
entre el mundo ideal,
el real y el reflejado,
y mantiene la tensión aún
no resuelta entre ellos
para contar una historia más compleja
que la que un espejo pueda reflejar.